oh dude this is so cool i can't believe
i never played this game
how do i get it
oh oh here we go
there's somebody open though right there
[Applause]
let's go
people of the internet's retro recontour
here and welcome back to another let's
play series today we play harry potter
and the quidditch world cup for the
first time i have a confession to you
guys i have never played this game
before ever
ever never rented it don't know why i
never played it i can't imagine i must
have been so busy with other things at
the time when the game came out for
whatever reason never played it you guys
in a poll that we did recently it was
one of the top vote getters i think it
was the top vote getter for best harry
potter game so i'm ashamed to say that
i've never played it but i'm gonna
correct it right now hope you guys enjoy
the video as always thank you all so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon
oh here we go man harry potter quidditch
world cup got the little spinning wizard
card right there oh this looks nice
ready to load do not touch the memory
card in slot a or the power button yeah
we're sticking with the gamecube version
again guys
[Applause]
oh save game data was found that's
that's to be expected
[Applause]
press start to begin
yeah 2003 okay that's what i was
thinking
dude look at this slick
oh man i'm digging this so he looks like
world cup is locked fortunately you have
not yet won the quidditch cup at
hogwarts which means you haven't had
privilege of attending the quidditch
world cup okay i'd suggest you go to
hogwarts right away and try to win that
cup okay so we gotta win uh the hogwarts
cup first here okay let's try with
special moves do we have any
okay everything's locked there
new cards do you have any cards yet
there's a hundred and four quidditch
cards
oh wow this is cool
this is really cool
all right
man they did a great job with these
menus though right
like everything is so nice and slick of
course you still got the
annoying loading in there but
all right so i guess exhibition would
just be if you wanted to like practice
around or whatever so i guess we go
straight into hogwarts right here
let's dive right in shall we welcome to
hogwarts hey harry now that you're here
you can choose which of the four house
teams you'd like to take through to the
quidditch car looks like the voice sink
is a little bit older
hufflepuff or slytherin
once you've chosen your goal you can
guide them through a series of house
challenges
and if you're successful in these
challenges then your team should have
enough skills to compete in the hogwarts
quidditch cup do you look at the people
you might even win it
over to you
would hey
oliver wood
what's up dude
no
quidditch is easy enough to understand
there are seven players on each side
in each uh each roll
this ball is called the quaffle the
chasers throw the quaffle to each other
and try to get it through one of the
hoops to score a goal
10 points every time the quaffle goes
through one of the hoops
now there's another player on each side
who's called the keeper i'm keeper for
gryffindor
i have to fly around our hoops and stop
the other team from scoring yep dude it
looks like ron in the back like right
above his head
to the if you're looking at the screen
like slightly to the left
rewind it go back and look i think it
was ron up there
hard to tell for sure but
oh
the bloggers walk around similar to the
scene
that's why you have two beaters on each
team
it's their job to protect their side
i feel like that would be the funnest
position by far like your job is
literally just to fly around
and hit the ball as hard as you can to
try and get it to hit someone else
three chasers try and scare the quaffle
the keeper guards the goal would be what
i would want to play beaters keep the
bludgers away from their team
now the last member of the team is this
seeker who doesn't have to worry about
the quaffle or the bludgers yeah yeah
this is the golden snitch and it's the
most important ball of the lot
it's very hard to catch because it's so
fast and difficult to see
it's the seeker's job to weave in and
out of the chasers beaters bludgers and
quaffle to catch the snitches
seeker because whichever seeker catches
the snitch wins his team an extra 150
i'm really curious how they handle that
too
a game of quidditch only ends when the
snitch is caught
any questions because the points staying
at one quidditch it's always been a
little
weird right one other thing before you
choose your house team if the team you
select does manage to win the hogwarts
quidditch cup you'll be awarded a ticket
to this year's quidditch world cup oh so
that's how we got up you'll be able to
choose an international team to support
right through the tournament oh that is
awesome
let's go
so if you'd like to choose your house
team we can start to play quidditch yes
let's do it i'm ready to choose
okay loading not nearly as bad oh dude
look at this
malfoy for slytherin
oh dude was that wait is that cedric
and cho right
i think i'm remembering that correctly
it could be i guess it could be anybody
but i think they mean for that to be
cedric he was definitely hufflepuff and
then that almost certainly looks like
cho to me
so you guys know man you guys know i
know my slytherin audience out there i
know you're upset because i got it i'm
choosing gryffindor
the first thing you have to do is learn
the skillshare i'd love to know
now let's go meet the rest obviously
where gamecube and ps2 weren't
and xbox weren't really online much i
guess xbox was but i'd love to know the
stats of like how many people actually
chose one of the other
teams other than gryffindor because you
know most kids are like oh yeah i'm
being hairy i'm choosing harry's team
for sure
okay so we've got okay that one's locked
special moves combos okay so combo
special moves beaters and plungers is
all locked so i can do seeker tackle and
shoot or passing
tackle and shoot
and then we've got records down there uh
let's do passengers we're just going to
griffin angelina johnson schools my
house challenge is all about passing the
quaffle that's pretty awesome that they
got all the names correct
we'll see as we go but uh that that
gives me uh okay wait so press a to pass
learn how to pass the quaffle while the
magical rings floating between your
chasers or green pass the quaffle
through them if you miss a ring or the
quaffle passes through one while it's
yellow you'll incur a time penalty
interesting okay so i mean i guess just
this challenge is all about just two
buttons
your three chasers will be flying in a
v-shaped formation and between each
chaser you'll see a magical ring
these rings will cycle between yellow
and green the chasers must pass the
quaffle back and forth through the rings
while they are green
whoa
through a yellow ring
to turn red and a time penalty will be
okay oh if you hold it
it like charges up here to pass the
quarterback press the action button
and you don't really control the up and
down
oh no no
what why is it not going through
oh i did a yellow one right there
here we go
darn i was hoping that one would change
yes it changed to green right at the
last second
wow we've won a new quidditch card let's
go
oh the penalties count for oh i still
beat the record though let's go it was a
30-second penalty my total time was 105.
dude we could totally we could destroy
that time
we could absolutely destroy that time
oh here we go with our save slot
brilliant we've won our first quidditch
card the more cards we win the more our
team will be able to do
these cards will open up all sorts of
other things too
anytime you like as long as you're not
actually playing
press this button and select the view
cards option
use the control pad to cycle through the
cards we've collected all right gotcha
harry okay
uh let's see
and it had like a i felt like there was
a hair stuck on my hat or something
don't you hate that when like just just
like a small glint in your vision
something was throwing me off i think i
got it though okay what is the remember
all i didn't even look and see what that
oh it's just where you can save game
preview movie all right
let's go look at the card that we got
okay it was one of the special cards
oh wait how do we know it just says one
of 104
oh it's lighting up the hufflepuff one
is lighting up over here
see what we got with hufflepuff
there it is right there
dude i love the attention to detail with
this man
like how you can tilt them around like
this oh i don't know what kind of
hogwarts legacy collectibles they're
going to have in that game but they got
to come up with something because wizard
cards
wouldn't have been invented yet if i
remember right
but dude this is so cool man
nothing on the back of it though
surprised it doesn't have a little bit
of like information that's fine though
it's still pretty cool all right let's
go back to the main menu
and let's see if we have another lesson
with angelina or if we need to move on
to the next person there okay quidditch
cards yeah we're just gonna press a to
continue
another loading not too bad though the
loading is really not too bad okay
tackle and shoot
wait why does it say record not set
player time not set dude i set the
record come on
oh wait no no no
there we go it automatically moved me
over
to uh is that katie bell
yeah so my the house record is 59 oh so
you could go even better
my player time was 105 yeah i could
definitely do better than that i was
just
figuring it out it's interesting to me
that it's kind of like a flat plane
though like you don't have to fly up and
down i i kind of like that honestly like
that was the biggest thing that threw me
off in the other name's katy bell yep
katie bell i played chaser for griffin
in the quidditch game in the other games
my house challenge throws me off i was
learning to tackle and to shoot at the
goals to tackle
tackle and shoot all right let's do it
okay so b is shoot and then uh a is for
tackle
tackle an opponent and score a goal
retrieve the quaffle from your opponent
using a tackle then attempt to score a
goal by throwing the quaffle through one
of goal hoops this is a one-on-one
challenge between one of your chasers
and a ghost is he a ghost edgar cloggs
is the ghost in question and he's been
hanging around the quidditch pitch for
as long as anyone can remember oh dude
that is so cool
you know how like a lot of racing games
and stuff they have ghosts that you can
oh got it from him and throw it into one
of the goals
what was his name edgar come here edgar
give me that quaffle
all right so you can charge it up as
well i figured out if you hold down b
just like with passing with a all right
come here you
trying to set that high score
all right let's see which one he goes to
guard he's going over there
48 seconds what was the record i don't
even remember quidditch we got another
card though
okay total time 48 team record beaten
all right save and continue dude i don't
really think i need to save after every
single one of these do i
i mean we'll go ahead and save this one
but it's like come on dude it's not like
it's a story game
it's just a habit though from playing
story games a lot it's like oh i need to
save constantly
okay so we got those two it's pretty
cool so far interesting how they're
handling it i'm curious to see how it
all
shakes out once you're actually in a
real game so house record is 43 seconds
there
59. okay let's let's see how they
handled the scene my name's
[Applause]
oh man you guys can't really see the
time can you let me uh i might actually
move up the cam for this game a little
bit
a golden snidger has escaped from a
snidget reservation and because i'm a
seeker i've been asked to catch it this
is a good
opportunity i'm
okay so again you don't have to worry
about the vertical
flames
i will peel off and leave grabbing to
him center the trail
yeah i'm not i'm not really making him
go up and down
i just need to control make sure he
stays on this so it's it's very similar
to how they handled it in the uh oh here
we go
got it great is that it some new
quidditch cars
29 seconds school record beaten three
quidditch cards one first match unlocked
okay i'm just gonna hit continue i'm
really i'm not gonna save after every
single time we do this
but yeah we'll see as the match goes i
want to see when we actually your first
three house challenges
and you're now ready to play a real
british match oh yeah let's go
uh only the team with the most points
wins the quidditch cup remember from
here you can replay any hogwarts house
team to better your score
so basically it's like you can guarantee
that you win personal hufflepuff is
locked versus slytherin is locked
so i guess we have to play each of the
teams and we could also go back to the
challenges
yeah i'm going to keep the webcam here
but we might move it again i want to see
what it looks like once we actually get
into the quidditch match because i want
to make sure as much of the screen as
possible is open to you guys
all right let's go ahead let's let's do
this man take on ravenclaw
we'll see just how ready you really are
let's play for the quidditch cup
i think we're ready
okay shoot uh yeah that's it i mean
that's all the broomstick control so
wait what about the they never taught me
about the beaters and the uh keeper
thanks lee i'm really looking forward to
today's match for today's match the
referee will be
you guessed it
oh dude this is so cool i can't believe
i never played this game
how do i get it
oh oh here we go
there's somebody open
though right there
[Applause]
let's go
right off the jump there oh look at this
we got a little celebration too okay
okay
all right so we gotta
remember that tackle move right
is that not a penalty okay you're just
like oh dude we're dominating
okay so what about the snitch though
[Applause]
wait why did they
oh see i don't like letting the passes
kind of float
[Applause]
i like holding down a to kind of charge
it up
dude the celebrations are awesome
okay we're up 30.
so ideally we'd get up like 160. so even
if ravenclaw i don't know
i thought somebody was over there no
right there to you and then you throw it
in
oh man
we're dominating so either spot though
bottom right or bottom left
should be fine
for the webcam i'll keep it there though
what did we get a quidditch card for
dude this is really fun
i'm still curious about the snitch
though
there's that like little
hold on hold on look at the top if you
look at the top of the screen like where
the score is
there's like a snitch slowly
i wonder if that's based on score
or if it's just like a timing thing
let's see if it moves a little bit more
i do think it hinged forward
[Applause]
okay this is clearly like easy mode i'm
gonna need to turn it turn up the
difficulty or something because
imagine if ravenclaw just caught the
snitch right now though
yeah this is definitely easy mode
they're just like
basically i guess slowly introducing you
to the game
because every time i there's like no
block whatsoever
whenever i try and tackle them to get
the
waffles
she's
because if you think about it like if
you were playing like legitimately
playing quidditch
that opening of the match would be super
important because
your goal as the chaser is just you want
to try and rack up 160 points as quickly
as possible
because any time you don't
anytime you're oh that one they did
block
do it at the wrong hoop though
[Applause]
like do we even really need the snitch
man i think it'd be so much cooler
oh they went over there and blocked that
one
[Applause]
oh dude you can hear the crowd chanting
whoa oh they stole it from me that time
okay
i'm trying to like figure out how to
change
[Applause]
oh right there we got somebody wide open
go for that left one
oh what a save though
i gotta save that one the snitch is
almost like
see there at the top it's almost reached
the other side she's the one you want to
watch if you want to learn how to really
jack him
oh i put the heat on that one too and
then
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's go
are we 150
i think that one i think that might be
140.
[Applause]
it is it's gonna be 140. it's almost
time for the snitch
dude i actually do not remember if
quidditch can end in a tie or not
can it end in a tie
[Applause]
[Music]
so we just got 150 all right so the very
least we're not gonna lose
even if ravenclaw caught the snitch
right now
[Applause]
so i guess they're just like waiting for
the seekers to spot it
[Applause]
so as i guess i'm number one on the left
over there
and then maybe the uh
ravenclaw secret is number two
oh no
yeah i guess it does kind of block the
webcam does block number two
it's all right you guys mainly need to
know where i'm at
oh come on
[Applause]
i'm pushing b
he's not grabbing it
maybe i need to get a little closer
there we go there we go
let's go
300 to zero
that's what i'm talking about dude
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight
dancing at the griffith commonwealth
tonight oh you gotta love it man you
gotta love it
oh that was awesome match result
gryffindor wins 300 to zero yikes
yikes sorry my ravenclaw's out there
y'all sorry to the ravenclaws six
quidditch cards won new challenges
unlocked okay
so that was clearly like the tutorial
match they they were not really posing
much of difficulty
so we played one game we've won one
uh slytherin actually lost a hufflepuff
but they did score a hundred wait
slytherin scored 150 points and lost
oh no slytherin yeah they did they
scored 150 hufflepuff scored 300. so it
was tied
it was tied 150 150 and hufflepuff got
the snitch that is awesome man the
gryffindor hufflepuff 1-0-1-0 right now
ravenclaw and slytherin fall to 0-1
now i think we should get to check out
the beaters and then the special moves
hopefully should we unlock that one too
yes both of these are unlocked
okay so we're gonna come back oh well i
set the record with harry right there
first try so we got all the way to the
gold
yeah we'll come back with those another
time and try to set all the records well
let's go ahead and talk to is this fred
or george i'm fred weasley
george and i the team's beaters
229 is this challenge is about beaters
and bludgers
yes this is the one i most wanted to see
how they handle it
i most want to see how they handle the
beaters
okay so it's why we use y to
i guess hit the bludger because it just
says bludger right there
in this challenge you'll be learning how
to defend against bludgers or one of
your chasers flanked by two beaters that
is george and me
will be searching for targets placed
throughout the grounds
what the beatles have to do is whack a
bludger at each of the targets
sounds simple enough what except once
the bludger has hit a target it will
rebound and pursue the chaser
relentlessly until the beast
avoid the bloody
i have no idea how to hit
like obviously i'm hitting okay press y
pressing y
oh use use the
left stick to control board
okay so wait why was that one not green
and then it's red
okay
i'm pressing y every time
where's another target
[Music]
i think it's coming back and hitting me
is the problem
oh no wait where's the last target
i don't see it
i don't see a target
okay this one was the most confusing by
far let's have another try that one yeah
we're gonna do that one again
all right let's replay it
learn okay let's read a little bit i
don't think i read at all this time fly
around the area and seek out the targets
once you've found one launch a bludger
okay so
i'm making it too difficult i don't need
to think of the bludgers as flying
around
okay then it says once you've found one
launch a blood dread and don't forget to
get out of the way when it comes back in
this challenge you'll be learning how to
use it
all right so i guess we just need to
fly in the direction over here of a
target
okay
i don't understand use use the left
stick to avoid the blood
i did
it just comes after me
i am so confused
maybe it's the right stick
avoid the bludger
oh
i have to kind of maneuver
so it goes into freder george instead i
think
at least that's what i did that time
okay where is that final target
it's the same problem as before where
the heck is the final title
what
what is happening
is it glitched oh it's over there by the
water yeah we're gonna lose again
it's all right we know where it is now
come on
oh no we missed
[Music]
okay we're terrible beaters the one that
i was most looking forward to playing
we're absolute garbage of this one
i feel like pressing x is like moving me
up and down though am i crazy
in this challenge you'll be learning how
to
i'm gonna i'm gonna push it right here
at the beginning
all right now
oh there we go i dodged it
all right
okay now i just have to like
yeah you just have to move out of the
way so that it it goes toward thread or
door it's kind of weird though it's a
little clunky
it's like i don't really have much
control over this at all
there we go
if you guys out there remember a better
way to do this
let me know in the comments because like
i said i never played it before okay we
got all greaves though so i guess i
figured it out
guide it guide it guide it
don't let it hit her
come on fred get it get it fred oh that
one actually hit me
i still think i did a really nice time
new quidditch card
okay team record beaten we only had one
penalty that's not terrible that's not
terrible i'll take it especially after
how we started off my goodness we were
terrible at the beginning of these guys
terrible
all right special moves
so we set the house record or no we
didn't we set the uh
the team record
our school record i don't know what we
said but whatever it was there's a house
record that is 106.
that one we just destroyed we went all
we settled set the school record on that
one
all right last ones find out what
special moves i'm alicia spinette i'm
chaser for gryffindor
i'll teach you about dodging and special
move tackles
dodging and special move tackles
i guess we unlock more okay
x is dodge i felt like i was pressing it
and it was making kind of like a weird
invalid sound or something okay learn
how to dodge and how to perform special
moves retrieve the quaffle from your
opponent using a special move tackle
score a goal by throwing the quaffle
through one of the goal hoops
okay shoot and special move okay wait so
b is also special move
uh let's see using a special this is a
101 challenge between one of your
chasers and our old ghostly friend edgar
cloggs edgar's going to try and take the
coffee from your chaser and prevent them
from scoring a goal egg is in a
particularly troublesome mood and your
chaser needs to employ the dodge to
avoid him you don't want a special
expert at the special needs
and this means it's going to be very
difficult for your chaser to keep the
coffin for longer than a couple of
seconds
what's that
harry here with a reminder press and
hold the special move to steer the
target over edgar release the button to
tackle
use the dodge button to avoid him and
the shoot button once you're in
arranging the goal loops
yeah they haven't really taught me dodge
at all
special moves so it's like you send that
over to him
and then you run and tackle him
oh that's pretty cool to give you a
little speed
i never even had his dodge but it did
give me a little speed
that had to be a pretty fast time right
house record beaten two quidditch cards
one
i'm gonna go ahead and continue moving
on we'll save here in a little bit so we
have done quite a bit and haven't saved
i'd hate to okay
select special moves in the inventory to
view all the moves you have unlocked so
far
press r
plus l plus b
what
r plus l plus b all i have to push all
three of those within the scoring zone
to perform special move shots
well why didn't you teach me that
during the
why didn't they teach me that practice
game nah dude
so you take the match with hufflepuff
would you yeah i would play for the
quidditch cup i made the best team win
let's do it cedric
okay bludger oh dude you got to do all
these things now dodge shoot so they
they've slowly added
little pieces for me to
be aware of here
again hey what's up
oh no
these two teams face yourselves
[Music]
all right here we go
[Music]
i missed it
it's not letting me do the dodge
[Applause]
for whatever reason the dog wasn't
working right there
[Music]
maybe you have to kind of like build up
to it or something
oh wait you can only do it when that
pops up
interesting and whenever there's
anything on screen that indicates that i
i have the dodge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i just tried to do the uh
hold l and r to do the special one
yeah nothing happened
maybe that's something else you have to
unlock as you go
hey let's go dude
completely different from the first game
there it was dodge again
oh wait it's saying that they like have
a dodge unlocked
she's so strong
that is why
flip it
spin it
oh
[Applause]
why was the bludger thing
oh dude this is awesome
oh wait why didn't it hit him i wanted
to hit them
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no
oh special moves
[Applause]
i pressed it i pressed it
yo let's go
you got some like mario
soccer
you know how mario tennis mario soccer
they always have the special moves
[Music]
yeah so when it pops up below like my
team is on the top left there
so it looks like right now hufflepuff
has
a dodge they can use
[Applause]
i'm confused about the blood yourself
like i really don't understand
because i hit that one earlier but it
didn't really
i wanted to go after them obviously not
my team that was the point of the
beaters you know they hit it at the
other team
they have defended a little bit better
than ravenclaw they blocked quite a few
of mine and like that time right there
you could see that they were
oh no okay so i gotta
[Applause]
oh i failed
okay wait so that must mean that i sent
the bludger but their team defended it
their team defended at that time
all right so watch i'm gonna try one
right here
[Music]
oh
i got it now but i
obviously didn't hit the
keeper that or the uh chaser that time
[Applause]
let's see it let's see it what's the
special move
oh oh oh oh fred and george look at this
look at this guiding us in
all the way to the hoop
just knock the dude straight through
the weasley what
oh i didn't catch the second word of
what he called it
okay i got another special move or
they've got a special move
[Applause]
okay so v
being underneath the name
i tried it didn't work
i tried the special move that time
oh wait i've got the special move on
defense
got it now got it got it
[Applause]
johnson wait if you see a blunder coming
can't i just like pass it
[Applause]
and see look i feel like the snitch is
going much slower this time
i don't know what controls that i really
don't maybe it's just random
[Applause]
i didn't even throw that one at full
speed i could have threw that one a lot
faster
[Music]
yeah it's still too easy right now to
just like steal from the other team
[Applause]
the scoring is only slightly harder than
this one i'm sure it's going to get a
lot harder when you get to like
the professional teams
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no
oh i can't throw it i can't throw it
right now i just have to
move around and try to get fred and
george to hit
[Music]
[Music]
no
okay that time special move worked
oh my goodness is that allowed madame
can you do that
is that allowed
i guess so
no penalty gryffindor 140.
get it back get it
[Applause]
yeah the tackle is way overpowered you
can just spam it
[Applause]
all right put this up 150.
see if we can get to 160. then i could
just let them catch the snitch
there we go dude
[Applause]
i don't even have to try now when it
comes time for the snitch
[Music]
we're about
[Music]
[Applause]
nice block though
[Applause]
i'll just score that way
i'll just score it that way
all right it's gotta be time for the
snitch right
where are you at snitch where are you at
oh now that one was a direct hit
now we got to do the team special
we got to do the team special after that
okay so it's the same move
[Applause]
i was like do they change it that'd be
pretty cool if they changed that one too
yep you know what's about to happen dude
[Music]
[Applause]
now the snitch look at that now it's
like not it's not as close
[Music]
because if you think about it right now
oh i get it dude
because hufflepuff has no reason
to catch the snitch right now
[Applause]
you know
so that makes sense like they're not
looking for the snitch is hard
so i feel like it actually went back
like when i scored that on the
hufflepuff side okay right there it did
move a little bit to the left
oh come on
it's about not to matter though
because ours keeps inching closer and
closer that way
because we keep scoring so it's in our
you know in our best interest is to go
ahead and get the game over with
[Music]
nice direct hit
angelina johnson oh look at that dodge
into the score 210.
[Applause]
okay it's so close now come on snitch
[Applause]
oh here we go here we go dude
yes see look their meter is i know you
can't see it very well their meter is
like super down low
oh yeah harry like instantly zoomed on
he had so much power right there
wow what an absolute massacre
sorry i'm sorry to my husband
[Applause]
wow dude i cannot believe i never played
this game i'm really surprised how good
it is
you guys were you guys weren't lying man
you really were not lying
about how good this game is it is super
easy right now that's really my biggest
complaint so far is super easy i want to
see how how the game mechanics evolve
and how they ramp up the difficulty
and and how that i love the system that
they've used though
for the snitch because that's always
been a problem in my head you know when
i think about quidditch
it's like
the whole idea of the snitch being worth
150 points so i love that little meter
and the fact that it went back that it
went down
like when i kept scoring for hufflepuff
because it's like they have no incentive
now to find it right they have they have
zero reason to try and find the snitch
so i think that's the logic behind that
and why it did that so
uh we're gonna stop there for today if
you guys enjoyed this make sure to give
it a thumbs up before you go that helps
more people find the videos as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon